my name is stan vermund i serve as dean
of the yale school of public health but
i wanted to just highlight uh the
partnership of yale university
with the american university of beirut
um you know uh the aub uh dates back
more than 150 years
founded um in 1866
and
there were there there was a uh
there were americans who were literally
fundraising to start this school in
beirut during the american civil war
just to give you a sense
and uh you know just after the american
civil war so
um the
university has been
a highly stable
academic force
with american
accreditation it was originally credited
by new york state educational
entities
and
all the many years
with all the trials and tribulations of
the middle east
aub has maintained its leadership role
in uh academia
and we're proud that that includes
medicine and it includes public health
and nursing so um
let me turn it over to dr khushnud
we have been um proud to be working with
aub for many years
and uh and uh we'll be hearing
from its former dean in just a moment dr
kushner thank you so much stan um again
i'm kaveh schnut at
associate professor yale school of
public health i've had the pleasure of
knowing dr iman for over a decade
and i'm delighted to introduce him to
you
dr iman nowahit is professor of public
health and occupation and environmental
health
at the faculty of health sciences at the
american university of beirut
he served as the dean for 12 years
at the faculty health sciences from 2008
to 2020
he's co-editor of the landmark book on
public health in the arab world
cambridge university press 2012
and he's a co-chair of the lancet aub
commission on syria
his research focuses on the health of
workers including working children
environment and health and conflict and
health
i'm so delighted that dr iman um he's
who's on sabbatical right now decided to
come to yale he's currently
in new haven and he's teaching the first
ever course called public health in the
arab world at yale college
uh dr iman thank you so much for joining
us i'll turn it over to you
thank you kavi and thank you dean
vermont for your kind words
let me start by sharing my first
slide here
so before i start i'd like to
first good afternoon to everyone who has
joined and i want to start by thanking
the
institute of global health
the school of public health at yale and
the macmillan center
council on middle east studies
for hosting this presentation
i want specifically to thank the
counseling on middle east studies for
hosting me for this semester at yale and
special thanks to professor marsha hoon
in hon
who was the force behind it
i also would like to
like to move the slide so
okay
i also like to
just recognize
my twelve brilliant undergraduate
students who took the course in public
health and artwork i would say
they were
quite an inspiration
the term shattered that you see in the
title of my presentation actually is
borrowed from this documentary
produced by uh director carol mansour
from lebanon
and it talks mainly about her
reflections on the
beirut explosion of august 4 2020
a year later and of course the shattered
here refers to the shattered windows and
doors and structures
but also to the shattered humanity that
we all experience at that point
my objectives here what i'd like to
share with you
and i'm putting them in a form of an
unusually for objectives in form of a
question because i'm still questioning
myself and i'd like you to so to join me
on this thinking of what plans should we
use to analyze public health challenges
and
i'm proposing a more or less a in a
different way of looking at time place
and person and i'll explain that as we
move forward
again this representation is not going
to be about the numerators and
denominators and really about
prevalences
few numbers here and there it's going to
be mostly focusing on the social
political and historical context
actually more on the political and
historical to just give a meaning to
why are we in the situation that we're
facing not only in lebanon and the
region
also um across the globe what lessons
can we learn to inform global public
health
and and what can we do all together
perhaps to achieve to
a further world
i'll start where you will not expect
i'm going to
define my place as minneapolis minnesota
my time as 25 may 22
and my person so this is the place time
and my person
his joy is george floyd
george floyd is
was
died at the age of 46 years he's a black
american
and he was a victim of police brutality
for different reasons one of them you
all know and that's
this the the color of the skin that he
carries
one of his last words
what he whispered before he passed away
was i cannot breathe
and
that incident
started a practically and a wide unrest
and social movement and political
movement across the united states and i
would say across three racial divisions
and geographic divisions
all calling for justice
not only for george justice for the
minorities the disadvantaged
underprivileged and i think there's an
important lesson that uh for all of us
this was 2020
i'm going to take you 10 years back
to banarus on 17 december
2010 again place and time when arus is
in tunisia and the person is
muhammad was easy was 26 26 years old
when he again fell a victim to police
brutality he was unemployed trying to
work
what was considered illegally on the
street
and in reaction he set himself on fire
his mom refers to this
as an act to defend his dignity
that incident
started what everybody talks about as
the arab uprising
the
that call for dignity for freedom for
liberation for the new world
uh actually swept the arab world and
many many many countries and capitals
actually saw
thousands and thousands and millions of
people taking to the street
demanding minimum
acceptable living conditions and minimum
dignity
i'll take you 10 years back
and again a younger individual
take it to gaza
on the 30th of september 2000
and the person in this story
is muhammad
muhammad was 12 years old when he was
caught with his father in a crossfire
between palestine and israelis
and he was shot by israeli soldiers
and ended
and his his father was was wounded this
took place around the practically within
every day or two
of the start of the
second in the father and
palestine
and that extended over more than four
years the pictures i chose here i chose
intentionally to show you that this is a
struggle between civilians
against young and old against one of the
mightiest
military powers
in the region if not in the globe
i can't breathe i'd like to adopt that
as a road map for global public health
i can't breathe
represents people who are fighting
racism and feeling that their
their
their structural and systemic
discrimination against them
i can't breathe
is a scream by
people in our region and most in many
many countries around the world
fighting at the against authoritarian
system against corruption
and i can't breathe art is the voice of
people who are still under occupation
and colonial powers
and in the three cases
what global public health can do is
actually be part of this
struggle of this passage of this journey
from racism
to a to a society or to a world where
people's identity and self-realization
is respected
to a world that moves from
authoritarianism
to perhaps in countries where
people are held accountable for
especially politicians for miss their
misdoings where they can live in dignity
and express themselves
again a passage a journey helping people
go from being under occupation
to a world with liberty
and freedom
if you think about this this is exactly
what we do in public health in public
health we talk about community-based
movements we talk about solidarity we
talk about action we talk about
listening to the victims we talk about
listening to our research participants
this is this is what i am calling for
here is to listen to people saying i
can't breathe and trying to work
together with them to a better future
i think this sentence summarizes it all
and this is uh from the landmark uh
report of the commission on social
determinants in 2008 that after all
social injustice is the main killer
in our globe it's a killer on a grand
scale
i take all of this to sort of put it
together in a model of high how i myself
look at public health and global
particle and i see here three
determinants
that actually
influence influence what we do
one is identity how we as individuals as
human beings how do we see ourselves how
to recognize
our identity and what we stand for but
at the same time this could be in
contrast and in conflict with how others
see us
the identity perceived by us
and and perceived by the other that kind
of conflict determines the health of
people and priorities of people
social determinants of health is known
to all of not most of us
it's it's it's about occupation and
finding it's about finding employment
it's about education
about these opportunities for better
life
and but i
i put political determinants of health
as an independent
domain and i put it on purpose there
because some people claim and say that
it is inclusive it is included under
social determinants i think we need to
split it out we need to have it out
there in our face because when we talk
about political determinants of health
we're talking about governance
accountability
corruption colonialism structural
violence this is what comes to our mind
when we talk about different political
determinants of health and it shouldn't
be diluted
by any way by just mixing it up with the
overall term of social determinants of
health and those three impact our health
not only at the personal level
also at the collective and population
level
the association of schools of public
health schools and programs of public
health uh here in the u.s in 2020 held
the leadership retreat this is an annual
event it was virtual the focus was on
structural and systemic racism of course
this was driven by george floyd's
case
and one of the most profound statements
i i i heard at the end of this panel
when the moderator asked the deans and
directors what is this one thing that
you would do in your school or program
addressing racism
and dean thomas lavist the dean of the
tulane school of public health said
we need to teach our public health
students the history of the united
states of america
for me this was a revelation
it's sort of again speaks to many of the
issues that we face not only in our
region across the world that there's a
history and there's a background and
there's a context for everything that
we're living in
and he has this movement that is a book
that is a documentary that as speeches
that he refers to as the skin you are in
the skin you are in different defines
you and i think this is again an amazing
statement because he didn't talk about
the color of the skin the skin you're in
because what's inside that skin is a
human being the anatomy whose anatomy
and pathology and physiology
and perhaps genetics are more or less
the same what differs is that
tiny thin envelope that covers our human
beingness and i think that's the kind of
public health that you should be talking
about crossing that barrier crossing
that skin to look at in depth at our our
humanity and and the and human beings
to add to these concepts that i'm
introducing
i would like to introduce the concept of
wounds
for traumas
and there are three uh uh
definitions or or terms that that are
used with ones one the invisible wound
we're used to talk about the visible
wound what we can see what the physician
can stitch
but we're talking about invisible wounds
that we cannot see that
are pushed inside and our job as public
health people our job as health
professionals is to uncover the wounds
inside these are the ones that are
caused by discrimination by injustice
they don't show up out there
these rules
could become intergenerational there are
now reports and studies talking about
slavery
and that it impacts even our genetic
makeup these wounds are transferred and
pains and sufferings are transferred
from one generation to the other and we
need to keep that in mind
and then the value of wounds it's not
stable we all know the narrative we
could know and draw the narrative and
how a wound was caused
who killed who shot who and who was the
belligerent and who was the victim but
the value of the wound and how do we
perceive it is defined politically
veterans in this country of the vietnam
war
have been treated differently than the
veterans of the gulf war
in the same country and that's defined
politically with the political agenda
and the mood of of the country and these
valley
news and how we see these wounds
internal and external differ with time
to the left of the slide there's a key
and i think this is a key that helps us
understand
what these wounds are but also this is
this key is a symbol and maybe i can
talk about it at the end or under qrij
it is also a political symbol
now i take you to lebanon and in my
presentation i'm going to zoom in and
out
and
and take you through this journey using
this concept that i presented as my
guideline
in beirut august 4 2020 6 07 pm
a time that nobody would forget
this explosion uh took place
this explosion now we have the time
we have the place but this time it was
not a person this time it was a
population
it was a whole collective experience
it destroyed a sizable portion of the
city of beirut
it killed
more than 200 people
it destroyed tens of thousands of houses
some of them severely damaged
it destroyed hospitals and health care
centers three of these hospitals were
severely
damaged
more than 6 000 injuries
were reported they stormed and the
emergency departments across the
hospitals in beirut and surrounding
towns and and cities
not only on their own they came with
friends they came with relatives they
came with their life loved ones
tens of thousands of people were
actually roaming around the emergency
rooms and around hospitals and the city
of beirut around that time
we were all worried about kobe 19
transmission there was no way to impose
any protective measure there
lo and behold
this is
august 4 here
and within weeks
the cases of covered spread out if this
is
a lesson of how politics and conflicts
connect with health i think this is one
of the striking examples
people would ask what's in that plume
and what kind of toxic
agents we were exposed to
but in lebanon at that time not only
people in beirut i think the
most
the strongest and the most common phrase
used was
i can't breathe
in arabic
i'm suffocating
people across the city and across the
country were talking about suffocation
and enable it to breathe because of the
smoke
because of the dust that was associated
with the destruction but also because of
this feeling
of total oppression or feeling that
this political system this situation has
dropped us off
what has been left of our dignity
and again
it connects to all these individual
stories
that i showed at the beginning
this is again a picture where you can
easily see the damage and you can easily
observe the
the external divisible wounds
the invisible wounds here
within this lady and others
are things that we need to keep
observing and monitoring and this is
what matters
because when you treat the visible wound
people are forgotten we need to keep
remembering that these wounds run deep
run deep to impact people's
feelings and people's mental health one
study that was done at the american
university medical center
and and our faculty jointly looked at
mental health disorders among their
children less than 18 years old and
again anxiety was on the rise ptsd and
depression
another colleague from our faculty
looked at injuries and has started now a
cohort of injuries i'm working with the
group across lebanon to try to
understand the interaction between
environmental exposure health outcomes
and vulnerability
just to let you know
none of these things were funded the
first two studies were done with no
funds totally on voluntary basis we've
been we've been reaching out to fund our
third the proposed study
for more than a year
there's no money to document what has
happened and this would be a missed
opportunity not only for lebanon for the
whole world to learn what can a blast
like this what kind of explosion like
this course do to people not only on the
visible but also on the invisible wounds
just to share with you the context
this blast was not an incident it's not
an accident
this blast is contextualized it's part
of
a stream of things that were happening
in the country
we published a paper right after talking
about the beirut blast and the
escalation of the crisis
at the heart of all of this
is a confessional sectarian political
system
at the heart of all of this
is political and economic mismanagement
and
when the two things exist together like
a country in lebanon you have the worst
combination ever any region that is
afflicted by
by by instability and wars
the turning point that history is long
but the turning point was february 14
2005 when former prime minister rafiq
hariri was assassinated
that please split the country
and within
less than a month we started talking
about and the country referring to two
political coalitions on blocks in 2005
the march 8 and the march 14
one with an orientation towards the east
and one with our on your orientation
towards the west
and that kind of polarization
impacted how the country is being run
and led
to further deterioration in the
management even of the basic services
provided to the citizens or the
residents of the country
we actually witnessed one of the
scandalous
unacceptable and unbelievable
garbage crisis that any country could
see in 2015
the country was drowning in in
in its garbage what you see here is this
river
this river is of white plastic bags with
garbage
that's what you see at the shows and
some of the thousand villages that was
another indicator of a failing
of the governing system a failing of a
political system a failing
tactically of a state
electricity was started experiencing
even further
electricity shortages and more
frequent outages
this is by the way the headquarters for
the
for the electricity of lebanon and it
tells you sort of is an indicator of how
bad the situation is
and think public health think health
outcome no electricity means your
medical equipment
are not running and you have to look for
alternative
sources of power this means that your
food cannot be stored this means that
if it is the bad weather
you cannot you can you you might not
succumb to the water elements
and
people reverted to alternatives and
these these uh this uh neighborhood
these degenerate generators mushroomed
all over the country with that came
earth pollution and and the fact that
people are and under our studied was run
by colleagues at the at the university
where it showed what when when you turn
them off and you turn them on
practically their particulate matters
and other toxins uh sort of go through
the roof
this led to social movements these
social movements were social slash
environmental slash political because
they followed
the the the garbage crisis and there
were demands part of a technical part of
its social reform and part of it
political reform and this is where
health politics social issues actually
come together and it's very difficult in
many cases to separate them from each
other
there was a hope there that perhaps the
social these social movements political
movements fresh
young people perhaps could could impact
the election the parliamentary election
2018. it didn't happen
it didn't happen because again this is
sort of a quick context because the
whole elector electoral law is based on
sectarian
divisions so this is the district of
beirut one and we have eight seats three
are reserved to the armenian orthodox
one is reserved to an armenian catholic
one foreign one for a catholic
one for an orthodox and one for a
minority you go to beirut two
you have six for the sunnis two for
shiites one for druze and so on so forth
in every single district in the country
what the
does that mean that if you are a
non-sectarian if you are secular
regardless of what ideology you you
carry if you want to change the system
you are focused whether you run for
election or you vote on the election
that your voice
counts and you have to follow the
sectarian divisions acknowledge the
sectarian division
um in the country
things got started getting worse and
worse on october 17 one of the minister
came up with an unpopular decision
and for a reason that no one understands
tens and hundreds and thousands of
people took to the street within days
there was an uprising people refer to it
as october 17 revolution in 2019. people
all over the country every city every
town every village went down there and
said it has to stop
things have to stop people should be
held accountable and things need to
change there was an amazing amazing
actually expression of solidarity when
the lebanese and others
joined hands from the north of lebanon
to the south of lebanon it was a human
chain of tens of thousands of people it
was interrupted in some places even that
interruption in the human chain had a
political connotation and political
explanation
it was peaceful
but people were angry and demanding
demanding accountability and of course
the response was brutal
and and and they were attacked and taken
to prison and injured
around the time that uh
october 17 uprising started
the banks closed its doors for two three
weeks
and when they opened all of us the
main is not even anyone who has an
account in the bank we had no access to
our money the door was closed from there
on
the banks gave us a stipend
they will decide on how much money we
can take from our savings account or our
current account in lebanese eras and
dollars or whatever other currency
this the the lebanese
pound the lebanese currency collapsed
for 30 years for 30 years it had it was
pegged at 1 500 lira's per dollar and
quickly over the last week you see it's
currently i think today it's close to 30
000 liras
per
per dollar
what does this mean just to give you an
illustration
so if your monthly salary was one
thousand one million five hundred
thousand liras at the end of 2019 that
was one thousand dollars salary
acceptable decent not great but decent
now this same salary is 60 dollars
on top of it you have no access to your
money if you have any um in the banks
which means that the purchasing power
of of the lebanese totally collapsed
lost lost more than 90 to 95 percent of
its value
hyper inflation in the country and a lot
of frustration on top of rudolph people
depend on remittances
the loved ones outside lebanon sending
some dollars and of course humanitarian
and financial aid from agencies
international and national
and then covered 19
in february 2020 i'm not going to talk
to about cover 19. and i'm not going to
talk about the response to government
i'm just going to say that government 19
came here and what it did politically
it stopped all protests in the streets
everybody went home
so it was locked down people went home
and every single expression of protest
or anger
went away because people were worried
about their health their loved ones and
they were taking this pandemic as they
should
very seriously
the european european report summarizes
this all in this quote
decades of political and financial
mismanagement combined with covered 19
and the august 2020 port of beirut
explosion have brought the country to
its sneeze
the world banks
the world bank stipulates that the
lebanese crisis
it could be possibly among the top three
most severe crisis episodes globally
since the mid 19th century this is a
record
for the country
the situation again according to this
european report poverty struck across
the population 74 of population
under
a sort of poverty constitution under the
land poverty
syrian refugees 90 in extreme poverty
most people receive two hours of
electricity per day the health care
sector is at breaking point
there's an exodus of health
professionals nurses physicians name it
and others and there's a shortage of
medicine and mathematics supplies
there's an issue a very basic economic
issue what currency to use to charge
people and to buy supplies there are two
different currencies that now don't talk
to each other and that are
are not controlled
and to top it all they expect that the
economy will further shrink
in 2022.
again another addition with the ukraine
war we all i didn't know but i didn't
know that close to 80 percent of the
wheat in lebanon is actually imported
from ukraine so this adds also to the
challenge of even putting bread
on the table
of course i did not forget the refugees
because the frankfurt is another
dimension
within the country that we need to
address
in lebanon there's more than one million
syrian refugees
that started uh coming influxing and
coming to lebanon as the war in syria
started in uh in 2011
and
and
on top of that we talked about close to
300 000 palestinian refugees with us for
decades
this uh
report from brookings talk about the
syrian refugees being a crisis within a
crisis i would say this is a crisis on
top of a crisis a crisis interacting
with a crisis
and
syrians most of them have no legal
residency
their 50 percent suffer from insecurity
food insecurity that doubled since 2019
90 percent live in extreme poverty
almost doubled since 2019 situation is
not much different for the lebanese
and the country also this is a point
that i would refer to later the country
also when you look at the at the health
care systems that are multiple health
care systems that address the needs of
different populations
you and hcr these were the refugees
you and your honor these with the
palestinians and then within lebanese
depending whether you have private
insurance or not is the minister of
health or social insurance that takes
care of you
but we don't live in isolation we're
part of a region and we need to
understand a little bit more how the
region is impacting us
and impacting it itself
this is the other word that we define as
22 states that are members of the league
of arab states
it's not a homogeneous region it's quite
heterogeneous a lot of inequities
actually it comprises some of the
wealthiest countries in the world and
also some of the poorest countries in
the world
i'm going to focus on two issues that
define the region a big time
one of them is conflicts
close to 50 percent of the arab
countries are in some kind of some
sort of phase of political instability
or an opinion war and conflict
what has changed there were wars before
the palestinian issue has been with us
for more than eight years
we had the civil war in lebanon 75 1975
to 1990. there was the iraq war the gulf
one gulf ii
and so they had these wars here and
there what has changed now in the region
that you have these multiple and
concurrent
conflicts
in the at the same time
they are protracted there are no more
quick wars
and i would say that the
situation now in the end
and also globally with these conflicts
that this idea previous idea that
there's a pre-conflict
uh phase a during conflict phase and
after conflict phase i think is that
that's the end of it we should declare
this that you can no more divide
conflicts into these three phases
they're mingled together even if the war
stops the conflict doesn't stop and the
fact that they are concurrent and
multiple they're speaking to each other
what's pre is poss for others
and again the high number of idps
internal displays people and refugees
the highest in the world
national borders are being broken down
within the country and and across the
region and again these wars are no more
national and local wars they are
regionalized and they are
internationalized
one
thing that was striking in these wars
that are happening now in the region and
unfortunately across other conflicts is
the weaponization of health using health
as a tool of war
it happens strikingly in syria
the syrian government and its allies
were clearly
uh
attacking hospitals and healthcare
healthcare workers
and this is happening in yemen saudi
arabia attacking health care centers it
happened if afghanistan even the u.s has
attacked health health centers whether
they claim it was
not on purpose or not the fact that
health care
facilities
is are becoming a target and now we're
seeing it also in ukraine
this is what i was talking about about
these huge
numbers of population that are shifting
within within these countries breaking
borders you have syrians in turkey more
than 3 million you have seen as in
lebanon more than 1 million you have 6
million syrians that have been shifted
displaced within the country itself
jordan name it there's
the the conceptualization of a national
border for a conflict is disappearing
our colleague omar dewacci and and and
his co-authors and colleagues have
introduced this concept that referred to
as therapeutic geographies which they
define as the reorganization of health
care within and across borders because
of these conditions a syrian refugee in
turkey is receiving a totally different
care you see a refugee in jordan or iraq
or lebanon or if they've gone to europe
and and within the same country they
could be receiving also a different care
you can no more talk about national
health system and consistent health
system
my dear friend and colleague
talks about these dichotomies that we
need to start thinking about
the conflict phase versus the post
conflict
are we dealing with emergencies or
should we think long term are we dealing
with acute illnesses and health problems
or chronic remember these refugees are
mostly from middle income countries
we're talking cancer chronic diabetes
heart disease we're talking injuries
we're not talking about diarrhea
and sanitation only
with healthcare systems
we need to address this issue are we
running parallel healthcare systems how
can these systems talk to each other and
integrate
are we do we limit our work to
humanitarian and then think of
development later or should they
converse with each other at this point
and again who is our target who is our
population is it refugees citizens who
takes priority and who deals with whom
these are really
very striking dichotomies that define
not only the health outcomes also the
health system and the priorities
el naughty
people are moving where
migrants whether because of
environmental migration or conflicts
from saharan africa
north africa or our region the levant
everybody is moving north for more
stability and for the
hope for a better life and more stable
life
the other issue in the in the in the
arab world besides
the
the uh
declare the uh
conflicts is the issue of ecological
sustainability which is actually
threatening the survival of the region
i'm not going to spend time here but i'm
going to share numbers if our population
today in the arab world is going to
double or increase by 50 if not double
from 350 people are saying to 500 or 600
million
in 50 years and if most of this shift is
in urbanization and larger and larger
urban centers and if
this region is the most stressed you see
that
here this region is the most stressed in
water availability
and it's expected if all these scenarios
for climate change are correct that will
be the first region to run out of fresh
water
and if
this continues that we're the largest
importance of syrian in the world
because we have added and semi-added
lands
you put all of these together and you
could really see what could happen
in the region in 20 30 40 or 50 years
time and if these predictions and
projections with climate change the our
region will be the hottest in the globe
and the least inhabitable in the globe
you're talking about migrations in this
case environmental on top of conflict
and economic and you can size it up
in your mind
the uh the uh
dpm of who amro speaks about the
challenges to actually achieve sdgs
governance weak governance fragmented
healthcare limited
data the emergencies and the conflicts
and of course
disparities
in equalities
i'm going to throw in a piece of history
here for the region
and of course this is a personal
perspective
i i think of three dates that are
extremely important
1918
this is when world war one ended
and there was a lot of aspiration in the
arab legion especially in the in the
levant sort of the
near
middle east
the western middle east and there was a
hope of an arab kingdom of independence
of self-governance
but again it turns out that the british
and the french empire decided to split
that region create nation states that
were put under mandate a nicer word for
colonialism for 30
years
1938 is another important date and
that's the time
and the year when oil was discovered in
saudi arabia that transformed the region
into becoming a very sensitive and
important geopolitical
area and it links to the whole question
of energy and sources of energy and of
course 1948 because the 1948 again if
you look at it that year presents the
uh
birth of a new state in the region the
state of israel versus the fact that for
the palestinians and the arab world it
is referred to as the catastrophe
it is the time when hundreds of
thousands of palestinians were uprooted
and forced out and that still defines
our relationships still defines the
politics still even defines this this uh
what we refer to as regional coalitions
and
and and orientation
for those who still
think that i'm
over uh claiming things
this line here in the arab world
to the north of this line
you find iran
iraq
syria and lebanon
this is one axis
this is an axis that is looking
east now in lebanon there is a division
and maybe that's where
some of the problems are
and to the south of this line
you have saudi arabia jordan egypt that
are looking west
you find that most of these countries
now are starting negotiating and accords
with israel and again it does define
the politics and the social structure
and stability or instability in the
region this is turkey
again interfering in syria
and libya and this is sort of the
regionalization of asia
this uh blue arrow here
is the nile river
and this night river again linking to
water scarcity and
link it to climate change
we know that what's happening now with
egypt sudan and ethiopia and the dam in
ethiopia this is a recipe for future
conflict whether we like it or not and
and again this is where climate change
migration conflict politics come
together
and then shouldn't be surprised why the
arab world is the
spends more on military than health it's
the only such region in the whole world
moving out to the globe
we're talking now about 84 million
forcibly displaced people i'm sorry
about that this was november 2021
because now we're talking about an extra
seven million ukrainians that have been
added to this statistic and this number
keeps increasing year after year that
tells you that there is a crisis in
humanity and there is a crisis in our
world and it's not necessarily
limited to one region or the other
some of the victims that we sometimes
forgot are the young
the children and the youth what we refer
to as the lost generation and you can
also build up
with your imagination what does it mean
when you have a full generation that
lost hope that was displaced didn't go
to school starved what kind of future
they have and how can they rebuild their
countries
coming at the end to hope
i have ideas here but because of time
i'm going to stop here
but share only one slide and say
i see a lot of hope in the young
generation
we have handed over to the young
generation a world in a total mess
and we're counting on this new
generation perhaps to do a better job
than our generation and and perhaps
uh try to
introduce real change
we have ideas for hope and change at the
level of the community and civil uh
movements
the academic the academic institutions
have a role and definitely
there's an important direction that we
should take and that's global solidarity
with that
i think i think our hopes winding
is still in our hands but we call the
shots i don't want to
take more time to
leave
time for questions and some interaction
thank you
dr yman thank you so much for this
unbelievable presentation uh it made me
very emotional i must say and thank you
for that final slide
the hope slide
because uh it again it really made me
emotional and also reminded me
why many of us got interested in public
health
and as you made these um
this amazing presentation it's really
making me think about how can we prepare
our students the next
kind of the future leaders in public
health
to be far better prepared than we are in
responding to armed conflict to
preventing these political determinants
of it because frankly
you were bringing up the importance of
history of public health which i
completely agree values of public health
um
honestly i don't think we are spending
enough time
uh
addressing those issues in our
curriculum so i i'm just thinking are
you
has the american university of beirut
faculty health sciences have they
re-designed their public health
curriculum to better prepare the next
generation of students
to understand because armed conflict is
kind of a new thing for many public
health um schools in the united states i
must say only a handful of them have
some sort of a structured program for it
it's kind of seen as outside of the
scope of public health so how do we
train
the next generation of public health
leaders to be far better prepared than
we are in responding to armed conflict
that's just some question that came to
my mind i don't want to ask the audience
to ask what put the questions the
chatbots yeah so uh gabby asked a very
important question but i don't want to
limit it only to conflicts and wounds i
think i think one of the issues that is
at the heart of public health education
and training institutionally and at the
level of individuals is the whole
concept of injustice
and i don't think we we do
the job that we expected to do there we
wait for incidents to happen and we
react to them we have to be proactive
and start thinking about what i'm i'm
not recommending that we only discuss
politics in classes we need to discuss
epidemiological statistics environmental
issues every single
core discipline within within public
health but the students the faculty the
institutions when they work together
they need to understand the context
what we did at the faculty we took a
bold step
actually in our vision
we introduced that we're a school
that is thriving or working or would
like to be leaders
pushing for peace
justice equity and health we've actually
put peace
justice and equity before have
and this is out of commitment it doesn't
mean that we're able to do it but i
think schools republicans need to
realize that we need to address the core
problem and start working and we need to
learn from each other you need to
instill values
and
sensitivity within the students in
addition to the skills that they need
and also we need to build institutions
and that's a role for the university
like here for the school like yes school
of public health and other schools here
that when they think about building
capacity it's not only about building
the capacity of individual researchers
here and there
building the capacity of institutions
because people leave i might be in
uas i might be in lebanon i might leave
lebanon or michael some one of my
colleagues might live in lebanon the
university says and the and the
investment should be at the
institutional level not only at the
individual level we've introduced a
certificate and several courses on
conflict within our mph program
thank you i'm opening up for questions
from the audience
let me just see the chat box
there's a question i see what kind of
partnerships
that can help lebanon deal with the
current concurrent health crisis
particularly partnership between
academic institutes and other agencies
in lebanon
okay i'm going to be here different
level some of them is very primitive
relative like the maslow's hierarchy of
needs that's sort of the bottom one down
there
i was talking to
dean
vermont to to stan a few days ago and
they said
my my visit
here to yale to spend a few months this
year gave me a breathing space
give me a at least
i have electricity around me i have
internet i have hot water i don't have
to worry about that every single minute
of the day
and i can think
i can talk to other people even even at
that level
please do not over complicate it even at
that level of if academics scholars
researchers can come over spend weeks or
months and go back i'm not talking about
scholars at risk staying here i'm
talking about people who come take a
breather and return i'm talking about
exchange of faculty
exchange of students
thinking about research that we can do
together there's a lot that we can learn
from our partners in the global north
but there's a lot that our partners in
the global north can learn from us how
to deal with these problems they're not
in any textbook frankly
they're not in analytics this is not
what we teach our students the the
textbook is being written and we need to
work on that and i think this is one of
the
some of the questions and dichotomies
that
our friend uh for advocate has posed
could be actually at the heart of some
of this work that we can do together
sorry i see a bunch of questions what's
your advice for understanding and
comprehending the complex and
multifaceted
history of countries that improve public
health professionals ability to be
sensitive and enable themselves to
adequately address the challenges of
these countries
um
i'm not sure i got the question fully
very broad question let me ask i see
michael mike mike pereira do you want to
ask your questions i see your hand
raise your hand
thank you dr nuai hit really it's it's
it's very
i think it's the perfect present
i want i wanted to say thank you dr
noahit for a phenomenal presentation
that really sums up decades of
you know inefficiency uh a lot of a lot
of problems uh in the region that kind
of mostly gets summarized by
you know in lebanon specifically a
country where people did not
not have to face any dictatorship really
had to uh you know had the chance to go
and vote
and they voted for the same people left
or right who kind of had opposing
political views but for 40 years did not
provide any sense of accountability a
system that was based on clientelism
where people who wanted to go and get
you know
a surgery that they could not afford
they would go to the politician
who would you know go and and and pay
for pay for that procedure if they
wanted a clear access to clean water or
a healthy and a good environment to live
in the clientelism of the politicians
was the thing that they feel that you
would only see that every four to six
years whenever elections would happen
the other comment i wanted to talk about
is about the healthcare education in
lebanon the issue is that we do have a
lot of public health education in
lebanon and universities such as aub but
we do not have a focus or emphasis on
healthcare management and healthcare
administration which does not i think in
my opinion equip the young lebanese
generation with
the principles to create sustainable
innovations because all what i see is a
lot of times
organizations ngos come into lebanon
they do a project
they they patch a certain situation but
we are not having a reform in a system
that is already broken on so many levels
so
i feel like if we need to make
change it has to be a big reform rather
just patching or covering holes uh
in the meantime
but thank you so much dr newey that was
an amazing presentation yeah michael uh
it's not that we don't have we have
several programs maybe we need more
and at our university we have an mph
program with concentration on health
management and policy we have an
executive master in healthcare
leadership
similarly with several other
universities in the country do we need
more yes
but again i would like to see these
programs contextualized and move from
the technical
of health care management to looking at
issues that like the issues i've
described
a while ago
of of how to deal with these dichotomies
and these complexities
and
we have an opportunity
to to to to look at our condition and
i'm i'm sorry to use the term as a lab
as an experimental lab to actually
examine that and report on it and test
it
and uh
with total transparency
uh over there
thank you i apologize we are running out
of time because i know dr iman has
another uh meeting right after but
why don't you ask the last question
thank you so much doctor in my head um
i'm actually an aub alumni myself i just
graduated from their medical school last
year and i came to the yale school of
public health to pursue a master in
healthcare management um thank you so
much for your presentation my question
to you is you mentioned the political
determinants of health
and in a country like lebanon where a
lot of the political influence is
foreign
how can you take a proactive approach to
public health
within that political determinant of
health sphere
when when so much of it is out of your
hands it's just the government that
that's either east or west like you said
there's no
continuity there so i was just wondering
what's it what's a proactive approach to
that in your opinion
um
definitely
one one i used to present to the board
of trustees at the ub and to at many
conferences i used to say
we are an activist school of public
health
and i don't think we should be ashamed
of that the we need to start looking at
these cases there and
not necessarily with with set answers
but we need to start
examining
these issues we're not
so you're right you're right that you
you have this general feeling that uh
uh that
it's out of our hands we have the most
corrupt perhaps political system ever
it's sectarian what can you do i think
what we can do is continue
to to work
in spite of
of these obstacles
continue dreaming of a better
way of a better
society and of a better country
for you as a physician
look beyond the the clinical look beyond
the disease to try to look at this wider
disease that that we're all uh
suffering from which is social injustice
i think these are the concepts that we
need to
start introducing we haven't done enough
and that's why you're right maybe we're
not ready
we don't know how to deal with it but i
think we need to challenge ourselves and
commit to that to start looking very
different and this is not
this is not about lebanon i think it's
the us as much as europe as much as
africa as much as
the middle east as much as asia we all
need to
do that i see a note here from a dear
friend saying we need to address the
politics of public health true
we need to not to be shy
to shy away from
talking politics not
engaging in the politics necessarily but
talking politics and making sure that
there is a political context and
dimension
to public health it's not a technical
field
politic health is not a technical issue
health is a political issue is a social
issue and it's determined by the
conditions we live in we work in by all
these different structures
that that determine our lives and and
our futures and the future of our
children
last question from peja
i thank you so much for for the
presentation my name is from sudan uh
it's actually a comment uh more than a
question i just want to say at this at
this point the first thank you for
presenting this because i didn't know
the situation in lebanon and it's so
much replicated at many of country in
the countries in the regions uh one of
the things that we are start talking
about in sudan that now we need to work
outside the health field to tackle the
issues of health so we start to talk
about now we need to politicize help to
make sure the politician now they
consider health as part of their agenda
which is not really happening because
when um when a political decision
happens and the health
have been impacted there is no actual uh
action to happen in terms of uh what can
we do and so on so thank you very much
for this presentation and we are looking
forward for uh more discussion in this
issue
and i look forward to hearing you
talking about sudan again in the context
of africa and the arab world because
your your situation is as complex if not
more than ours good luck to you
uh thank you for all the participant
thank you so much dr iman we should have
made this much longer
than an hour because there's lots and
lots of interest in conversation with
you but hopefully we will have
another talk with dr iman thank you so
much really appreciate it
thank you all